hitting theaters in June is towns
action-packed reboot of the bumming Show
Me The Mummy welcome to a new world this
is the one I'm really excited about
I like that I like that all kidding
aside The Mummy is not for the faint of
heart
people are gonna jump it's so much fun
to make your playing anything to seal
its scent in around its modern day it's
very scary 2,000 years ago a princess is
buried alive when Tom unearths the mummy
put on his plane all hell breaks loose
zero Niner Niner
there's some scenes and sequences in
here that are really epic sofia boutella
plays the mummy with anger issues she
would no stop what was it like working
with Tom Cruise how much fun was that
he's so on top of any he knows what he's
talking about and he loves making movies
now we're gonna do this very cool friend
that's Russell Crowe Tom mixes it up
with the story is loosely based on the
1932 classic starring Boris Karloff was
the first blockbuster for Universal
Pictures so it's more in the classic
vein of the original this is a real
monster movie it's also gonna have humor
romance and thank you very scary
now Universal is planning for The Mummy
to launch the return of a bunch of
classic monsters including The Wolfman
The Invisible Man and the Bride of
Frankenstein the plan is to have them
all intersect in the future in the same
way the Avengers are doing
[Music]